President Trump says he is well prepared
for that meeting with North Korean
leader Kim jong-eun but he also says
attitude is more important than
preparation Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo says the stakes are high when mr.
Trump and Kim talk about defusing
nuclear tensions we want to achieve a
fundamentally different strategic
relationship between our two countries
we are we believe it's important to take
down the threat from the world a
completely denuclearize North Korea in
exchange for that we're prepared to do
things that provide them two security
assurances that they need Ben Tracy is
in Singapore with more on the
much-anticipated meeting Ben good
morning
a good morning this is no doubt the
Superbowl of political summits and
everyone here is now just waiting for
President Trump and Kim Jong moon to
arrive now over at the capela hotel
where the summit between the two leaders
will take place that's already on
lockdown and closed to the public there
is also a visible security presence at
the hotels where President Trump and Kim
Jong moon will be staying Singapore is
designating the zones around those
hotels and the summit location as
special event areas with stricter
security including special forces
there is also airspace restrictions
including a ban on drones now what is
still unknown is what if anything this
summit will actually accomplish will
this just be a meet and greet between
these two unpredictable leaders or will
they reach an actual agreement on
getting rid of North Korea's nuclear
weapons program and perhaps an official
end to the Korean War now typically the
result of a summit like this is agreed
to before it even begins but that does
not appear to be the case here so that
certainly raises the stakes and
president Trump will get more of that
made-for-tv drama that he seems to like
Vlad Ben Tracy in Singapore thank you
for more on what may come from the
summit we turn to Michael Mazar he's a
senior political scientist at the RAND
Corporation welcome to the table nice to
be here
so to Ben's report what are you
expecting from this meeting a meet and
greet or something substantial so
something in between I think the meet
and greet is the most important part
just to see how they get along it's too
short of a summit and there's not been
enough preparatory work done to it
back to some kind of grand bargain where
everything is resolved but there should
be at least a road map that they can
agree to with maybe some initial steps
in the right direction you talk about a
road map if you look back over time
maybe go back to 1994 or even 2005 we've
had negotiations before with North Korea
what did we learn from that that makes a
certain and what needs to be done now
well a couple of things one is that
North Korea has an incentive to draw
these things out and and delay and find
ways to kind of stretch the negotiations
without actually giving up what it's
trying to achieve but the biggest
question right now is how different Kim
jong-un actually is there are
tantalizing signals that he really cares
more about the economic prospects of his
country than his father or grandfather
what he's willing to give up to get that
right is the situation is that well not
at once not at once the question is and
the president Trump's referred to a
process here so the question is can you
get some initial concessions that give
everybody a sense that North Korea's
moving in the right direction and a
clear plan for over a number of years I
think everybody who studies this
realizes it will take a while but at
least if we have some clear milestones
that we're moving toward we'll know
we're moving in the right direction and
that ought to be enough out of an
initial summit Michael when the
president says that he doesn't need much
preparation for a meeting like this or
that he's been preparing for his entire
life does that give him the upper hand
does that put him at a disadvantage or
perhaps neutral I don't know that really
makes a lot of difference I think
clearly secretary Pompeo has been
working with the North Koreans very
closely it sounds like they have some at
least initial statements agreed and the
North Koreans have given some assurance
of a handful of things they're willing
to agree to but one that we know from
summits is by far the most important
thing is the personal chemistry between
the leaders that comes up whether they
develop trust whether they actually like
each other I don't know if that's
possible in this case but that's the
most important thing I'm going to be
looking for is whether the two leaders
seem to be getting along and
establishing a basis of trust that can
move forward we've heard some talk in
the last week about a rift between
Pompeo and Bolton how does that factor
in when those are two of the closest
advisors to the president right now on
right yeah I mean I don't know to what
extent that's true I think the way it
factors in is it just gives the
president a choice always in those cases
it comes down to the president's
decision and the president will side
with one of the other side of his or
potentially her administration and then
that'll that'll be it unless one of the
other of those people then tries to work
under the table to subvert negotiations
or what the other side is doing I don't
get the sense that president Trump would
tolerate that from anybody so I think
he's made his choice which is to try to
move forward you know we have an open
and democratic society here so we'll
know how successful or unsuccessful this
meeting is how do you think it will play
in North Korea not just with the
hardliners in Kim's regime but the
people will they ever even get a sense
of what is happening in Singapore so
it'll play in two ways one is the way
the regime there wants it to play which
is of course the dominant way they will
broadcast whatever message they want to
and the primary message will be the
United States we forced the United
States to come to the table and they
recognized us in ways they never have
before that'll be their primary message
but there is a lot of information
getting into North Korea these days and
there is a sense that the North Korean
people have economic demands that they
haven't had in the past so there'll be a
short term message but then the
longer-term development of this whether
the North Korean people begin to see
benefits out of it
relief of sanctions that will be the
longer-term more important way in which
a message gets through to the North
Korean people all right all eyes on
Singapore Tuesday Michel Mazar thank you
very much as always CBS News will bring
you coverage of the historic meeting in
Singapore starting with our Sunday
broadcast we will also have updates
throughout the summit Jeff Glor will
anchor the CBS Evening News from
Singapore on Monday and Tuesday